Traductor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
En todos los tiempos
y sitios de nuestra historia
los humanos se han preguntado:
"¿De dónde venimos?"
"¿Cuál es nuestro lugar en este mundo?"
"¿Qué nos pasa al morir?"
Las religiones son sistemas de creencias
que se han desarrollado
y evolucionado a lo largo del tiempo
como respuesta a éstas
y otros misterios eternos,
motivados por el sentimiento
de que algunas preguntas
sólo pueden contestarse mediante la fe
aplicando una intuición
de que hay algo más grande que nosotros,
una autoridad más alta
a la que tenemos que rendir cuentas
o alguna fuente
de la que todos venimos
y a la que todos debemos regresar.
El hinduismo se refiere
a las religiones de la India.
No es una sola religión
sino una variedad
de creencias relacionadas
y prácticas espirituales.
Se remonta a cinco milenios
al tiempo de Krishna,
un hombre de gran virtud
que se convirtió en lo que se conoce
como el avatar de Vishnu,
una encarnación del dios
en forma humana.
Nos enseñó que toda la vida
sigue el karma,
la ley de la causa y el efecto,
y que nuestro trabajo es cumplir
con nuestro deber, o dharma,
de acuerdo a nuestro lugar
en la sociedad
sin preocuparnos de lo que pasará.
Al morir, nos reencarnamos en un cuerpo nuevo.
Si seguimos nuestro dharma
y cumplimos con nuestro deber
en una vida pasada
obtenemos buen karma,
enviando nuestra alma a un lugar más alto de la escala social.
Nuestro renacimiento en la próxima vida
estará determinado
por lo que hagamos en ésta.
La rueda del renacimiento
se llama samsara.
Es posible que una persona muy santa
lleve una vida con suficiente buen karma
como para liberarse de la rueda.
Esta liberación se llama moksha.
El hinduismo enseña que todo es uno.
El universo entero
es una realidad transcendental
llamada Brahman,
y hay un solo Brahman
pero muchos dioses dentro de él,
y sus roles, aspectos
y formas son distintos
según varias tradiciones.
Brahma es el creador,
Vishnu el preservador
que a veces toma forma humana,
y Shiva es el transformador,
o dios de la danza.
Durga es la madre divina,
celosamente protectora,
Ganesha tiene una cabeza de elefante
y es el santo sabio del éxito.
El hinduismo es la tercera religión
más grande del mundo.
Y aunque la mayoría
de los hindúes viven en la India,
pueden encontrarse
en todos los continentes,
con mil millones de seguidores.
Ahora, vayamos a Occidente,
cruzando desiertos y montañas
hasta el creciente fértil alrededor
de 4000 años atrás.
El judaísmo comenzó con el llamado de Dios
a Abraham y Sara para que
salieran de Mesopotamia
y emigraran a la tierra de Canaán.
Como recompensa a su fe
en el único Dios verdadero,
un concepto revolucionario
en el mundo politeísta de la época,
recibirían tierra y muchos descendientes.
De esta promesa viene la tierra de Israel
y el pueblo escogido,
pero quedarse en esa tierra
y mantener toda esa gente junta
iba a ser my difícil.
Los israelitas eran esclavos en Egipto
pero Dios los liberó con la ayuda
del profeta Moisés
quien recibió los Diez Mandamientos
y más tarde, cientos más.
Conquistaron la tierra prometida,
pero no pudieron mantenerla
por algunos cientos de años.
Israel está ubicada en una encrucijada
por la cual mucho ejércitos
pasaron durante muchos siglos.
Y en el año 70
los romanos destruyeron el templo
en su capital, Jerusalén.
Así que la religión se transformó
de una religión de templo
con sacrificios y sacerdotes
a una religión del libro.
Es por ello que el judaísmo es una fe
de simbolismos, reverencias
y significados profundos
atados a la literatura de su historia.
Las muchas escrituras sagradas forman
la biblia hebrea o Tanaj,
y cientos de debates escritos
e interpretaciones
están contenidas en un rico compendio
de significados profundos
llamado el Talmud.
Los judíos encuentran un significado
rico y simbólico en la vida cotidiana.
En la comida de la Pascua
cada platillo en el menú simboliza
un aspecto del escape de la esclavitud.
La importancia de crecer
se enfatiza cuando los jóvenes
llegan a la edad del bar y bat mitzvah,
ceremonias durante las cuales
se asume la responsabilidad
por sus acciones
y se celebra la unión
de sus propias vidas
a la fe, la historia y los textos
del pueblo judío.
Hoy en día, hay 14 millones
de judíos en el mundo,
6 millones en Israel
que obtuvo su independencia
luego de los horrores del genocidio
de la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
y 5 millones en EEUU.
Pero volvamos ahora a la India,
2500 años atrás,
donde comenzó el budismo
con un príncipe joven llamado Siddhartha.
La noche en la que fue concebido,
su madre, la reina Maya,
se dice que fue visitada en sueños
por un elefante blanco
que yació junto a ella.
Dies meses más tarde,
nació el príncipe Siddhartha
a una vida de lujos.
Aventurándose a salir
de su existencia protegida
cuando joven,
vió el sufrimiento humano
que le había sido oculto
e inmediatamente comenzó
a buscar sus causas.
¿Por qué la gente tiene que sufrir?
¿Debemos reencarnar cientos de vidas?
Al comienzo pensó que el problema
era el apego a las cosas materiales,
así que renunció a sus posesiones.
Se convirtió en un mendigo andante,
que lo hizo descubrir
que eso no lo hacía más feliz.
Entonces escuchó a un maestro
de música decirle a un estudiante:
"Si aprietas mucho
la cuerda, se romperá.
Pero no la dejes muy floja,
o no sonará".
En un instante se dió cuenta
que buscar respuestas en los extremos
fue un error.
El camino medio
entre el lujo y la pobreza
parecía lo más sabio.
Y mientras meditaba bajo un árbol bodhi
le llegaron el resto de las respuestas.
Toda la vida está llena de sufrimiento
que es causada por el deseo egoísta
de lograr las ambiciones propias
a costa de los demás.
Siguiendo un plan de ocho pasos
se puede aprender a
a reducir estos deseos,
y con ello la reducción del sufrimiento.
Ese día Siddhartha se convirtió en Buda,
el Iluminado.
No el único, pero el primero.
El método budista se conoce
como el Noble Sendero Óctuple,
y aunque no es fácil de seguir
le ha marcado el camino
a millones para su iluminación,
que es lo que significa llegar a ser Buda,
un estado de compasión,
sabiduría,
paz,
y disciplina mental.
Desde el momento
en que se levantó del árbol
hasta el momento
de su muerte ya anciano,
Buda le enseñó a la gente
cómo lograr la iluminación:
con el habla correcto,
el medio de vida correcto,
una mente enfocada en lo real,
y un corazón enfocado
en amar a los demás.
Muchos budistas creen en Dios o dioses,
pero las acciones son
más importantes que las creencias.
Hay cerca de mil millones de budistas
en todo el mundo hoy en día,
la mayoría en el este,
sureste y sur de Asia.
Hace 2000 años,
en la tierra prometida del judaísmo
nació el cristianismo.
Así como los hindúes llaman a Krishna
"Dios en forma humana",
los cristianos dicen los mismo de Jesús,
y el cristianismo surgió del judaísmo,
así como el budismo surgió del hinduismo.
El ángel Gabriel fue enviado
por el Dios de Abraham
a una mujer joven llamada María
para que fuese la madre de su hijo.
El hijo fue Jesús,
criado como carpintero
por María y su esposo José
hasta que cumplió 30 años
y comenzó su carrera pública
como la palabra viva de Dios.
Menos interesado en la religiosidad
que en la justicia y la compasión,
Jesús sanó enfermos con el fin
de atraer a las multitudes,
y les habló sobre su padre celestial:
afectuoso, indulgente y atento.
Así los invitó a todos a la mesa
para mostrarles que en el reino de Dios,
los marginados, pecadores y santos
comían todos juntos.
Sólo tuvo tres años
antes que su sabiduría poco convencional
lo metiera en problemas.
Sus enemigos lo hicieron arrestar
y fue ejecutado por Roma
con el método común
con el que los agitadores eran ejecutados:
la crucifixión.
Pero al poco tiempo de ser enterrado
las mujeres consiguieron su tumba vacía
y pronto se corrió la voz,
convencidos de que había
resucitado de la muerte.
Los primeros cristianos describieron
sus apariciones,
aumentando la creencia
de que su mensaje fue verdadero.
El mensaje: aménse los unos
a los otros como yo les amé.
Los cristianos celebran
el nacimiento de Jesús
en diciembre durante la Navidad,
y su sufrimiento, muerte y resurrección
durante la Semana Santa en la primavera.
En la ceremonia del bautismo,
el lavado de los pecados
y la bienvenida a la comunidad cristiana,
commemora el bautizo del propio Jesús
cuando abandonó su vida de carpintero.
En el rito de la comunión,
los cristianos comen el pan
y beben el vino
bendecidos como el cuerpo
y la sangre de Jesús,
en recuerdo de su última cena.
Hay dos mil millones de cristianos
en todo el mundo,
que representan un tercio
de la población mundial.
El islam comenzó hace 1400 años
con un hombre de gran virtud,
meditando en la cueva de una montaña
en el desierto de Arabia.
Este hombre fue Mahoma.
Recibió la visita de un mensajero divino,
nuevamente el ángel Gabriel,
Yibril, en árabe,
comunicándole la palabra de Alá,
el Dios único de Abraham.
En los próximos años,
más y más mensajes le llegaron
y él los memorizó y los enseñó.
Los versos que recitaba
estaban llenos de dichos sabios,
versos hermosos,
y metáforas misteriosas.
Pero Mahoma era un mercader, no un poeta.
Muchos están de acuerdo que los versos
eran de veras las palabras de Dios,
y estos creyentes
fueron los primeros musulmanes.
La palabra "musulmán"
significa aquel que se rinde;
aquel que se rinde
ante la voluntad de Dios.
Los cinco deberes más importantes
de los musulmanes
se conocen como los cinco pilares:
Shahada, en el que que los musulmanes
declaran públicamente
que no existe otro Dios sino Alá
y que Mahoma es el último profeta;
Salat, la oración hecha cinco veces
al día de cara a la Meca;
Zakat, donde cada musulmán debe dar
del 2 al 3% de su valor neto a los pobres;
Sawm, el ayuno durante las horas del día
en el mes lunar de Ramadán
para fortalecer su voluntad
y su confianza en Dios;
y Hajj, en el que una vez en la vida
cada musulmán que pueda
debe hacer una peregrinación
a la ciudad sagrada de la Meca,
para preparase para el momento
en que se presentarán ante Dios
y serán sentenciados merecedores o no
de una vida eterna junto a Él.
Las palabras de Dios
reveladas al profeta
en el transcurso de 23 años
están todas recogidas en el Corán,
que literalmente se traduce
como "la recitación".
Los musulmanes creen
que es el único libro sagrado
libre de toda corrupción humana.
También es considerado por muchos
como la obra literaria más fina
escrita en árabe.
El islam es la segunda religión
más grande del mundo,
practicada por más de 1.5 mil millones
de musulmanes en todo el mundo.
La religión ha sido
un aspecto de la cultura
que ha existido por mucho tiempo,
y existen formas incontables
de practicarla.
Pero lo que es común
a todas las religiones
es la búsqueda por el significado
que va más allá
de las vanidades vacías
y las realidades mundanas
de la existencia,
más allá del pecado,
del sufrimiento,
y la muerte.
Más allá del miedo
y de nosotros mismos.